how did Amex become the king of credit
cards the key to amex's business is not
high interest rates or high Annual fees
the key is the high fees they charge
Merchants visa and the MasterCard only
charge one and a quarter to two and a
half percent per transaction but
American Express charges one and a half
to three and a half percent per
transaction this may not sound like much
but an extra one percent on every
transaction adds up super fast because
of this most Merchants aren't a fan of
Amex but they're forced to accept Amex
because all the high Spenders prefer to
use AmEx and these high Spenders prefer
MX because of all of the crazy benefits
it offers and this ultimately creates a
super unique business dynamic